right and with the amazing been chef de
cuisine creator of lucky cap if it's one
thing you know you know how to make a
great cocktail pretty much yeah and
you're in love with Thai food yeah
Lao food is completely different right
yeah pretty much he'll bit spicier
fresher spicier lot less kind of spicy
they're just more like fresh ingredients
perhaps when it comes the great cocktail
yes since this is a coconuts this is a
pinochle out appeal at the Pina Colada
between the color
it's always ruins so they've got
pineapples
well you have just literally got this
morning in the market got you we've got
coconut cream yep I'm so just as what
doctors take it down to a nice syrup
[Music]
maybe it's the key sticky rice as you
can see it's pretty strong close oh my
it's clear it's a mixture between petrol
and cough medicine yes definitely I'm
definitely strong enough that palm sort
of tastes like a caramel sauce yes it's
just punching the ball with a bowl of
water really good unless it be a fresh
mint inside how pungent that mint is to
slough mint so it's a lot more
pepperminty than a brownie min that we
have
pinochle ow pinochle out I love that
name and the coconuts coconuts
everything's fresh
yep got porn on ice right in never gonna
blend it all up in our trusty bender in
our rusty blender rhino
not so now conserve to the monks bender
definitely not no house will be that we
having a good day but when we know holy
also that would be classified as a
naughty monk right definitely garnish it
with flour basil you've got all you've
gone all gone all chef again right here
we go big weirdest big kid look at you
pretend you my wife yeah see that's
lovely now battle issues yeah
also that whiskey now it's been diluted
yeah creamy and yeah mmm delicious turn
it upside down there ask me that
turn around take a little sip tippy you
know we know you love your cocktails
because I want to see there you go
I want to see those shorts got from Baby
Gap this morning from j.crew coming
first texture freaking delicious when
you do that or they pretend oh yeah okay
fine out with that
[Music]
why you ran
give the better every time
huh
[Music]
[Music]